I'm very entrepreneurial so like I think
of things that nobody else thinks of
things are getting heated behind the
scenes of the hype house a few members
are jumping ship alongside Daisy Kitsch
while Thomas petrol and chase Hudson
attempt to salvage what little remains
keep watching to find out why things got
sour between Daisy and the founders of
the hype house and watch until the very
end to find out what Charly's Emilio has
to say about this split people like each
other or not and like it's not fun to
fake things the hype house is home to 19
famous tick stalkers many of which
choose to come and go as they please my
job is to fill my life and my friends
after leaving Jake Paul's team 1021
year-old Thomas Petro joined forces with
seventeen-year-old chase Hudson to
create the tic-tock headquarters that is
hype house the creator collective was
formed in late 2019 and as of March 2020
it's already falling apart
turns out putting a 21 year old in
charge of dozens of teenagers is a
recipe for disaster
according to Insider the hype house
isn't what it appears to be many of the
smiles we see on our favorite tik-tok
errs videos are fake and easy Keach can
attest to that
most recently Daisy couch has spoken out
about the legal battle that is tearing
the hype house apart and it looks like
things are even worse than we thought
don't be fooled by the glitz and glamour
the hype house promotes things are way
less peppy and a lot more shady behind
the scenes Thomas and chase have been
widely recognized as the founders of the
hype house but according to Daisy that's
not exactly true while Thomas might come
off as the beloved hype house manager he
isn't all that friendly when the cameras
aren't rolling just like Jay Paul he can
be controlling going as far as to tell
Dixie D'Amelio that she's not allowed to
eat until she films a tik-tok video
Outsiders Daisy and Thomas's
relationship is one for the books but in
real life these two can't seem to see
eye-to-eye which is one of the many
reasons why hype house is splitting up
House members are forced to film a
minimum of three tic toc videos every
single day while juggling an education
and a social life nobody's got time for
that
things started to get ugly between Daisy
chase and Thomas when Daisy began
voicing her desire to be recognized as
the mansion's third co-founder she even
took to Instagram to give fans a
heads-up on what was really going on
according to Daisy when you start loving
yourself loudly and setting healthy
boundaries you're gonna piss off any
toxic people around you so clearly Daisy
is waving the red toxic flag in Thomas's
face and he's far from thrilled Daisy
ended her post by reminding fans to
never let them walk all over you but
what exactly went down between them and
why are legal actions being taken during
an interview with insider Daisy's lawyer
Chris Young revealed that Daisy is
officially leaving hypeeee house he also
stated that the tic-tock her plans to
create her own creator collective
however Chris explained that since
ongoing trademark disputes were afoot he
could not reveal whether or not Daisy
was allowed to use the heighth house
name but regardless not having a claim
to the hype house name won't stop her
from establishing a tick-tock collective
of her own but most surprising is the
revelation that Daisy is already in
talks with some of her fellow hype House
members and they're ready to jump ship
with her
turns out the hype house has little love
for Thomas Petro who had been pegged as
a tick-tock tyrant before we reveal
which tick stalkers have agreed to join
Daisy's cause let's talk about the root
of Daisy's legal battle and which
incident led her to confront Thomas
during a shoot Chris Young told insider
that Daisy is the reason tick stalkers
are allowed to rent the hype house in
the first place at the time the lease
was signed Daisy was the only one who
could qualify based on income so her
name is one of the few on the lease
Daisy revealed that she has received
zero recognition for her contributions
despite being a co-founder during the
same interview it was said that Daisy
and Thomas had been the ones who came up
with the concept for the tic-tock
mansion however dreams became a reality
when Thomas met chase but the pair never
praised Daisy for her contributions nor
did they include her in any of the
conversations back in January 2020 Daisy
filed three applications to trademark
the hype house and drama hit the fan in
February when Thomas used
trademark in an Instagram story
promoting hype House merchandise without
Daisy's consent
that's when Daisy's lawyers sent Thomas
a cease and desist letter
unfortunately Thomas chose to ignore
this letter and promoted hype House
merchandise anyway and well that's when
things got ugly between the tick talkers
in early March Daisy confronted Thomas
during a shoot leading to a verbal
altercation between the two
collaborators on top of using the high
post trademark Thomas gave contractors
the okay to make renovations without
consulting the landlord which puts
Daisy's deposit at risk and most
recently Daisy revealed that Thomas was
trying to rally other members of the
house against her to intimidate her from
coming into her own property well two
can play at that game we previously
mentioned that Daisy was recruiting hype
House members of her own many of the
House members have flocked to her side
however no concrete names have been
announced what we do know though is that
multiple tick tock errs have been
unfollowed by the group shared Instagram
account so far these members are Patrick
Houston Connor Yates Calvin Goldie and
Wyatt Xavier but what about group
members like the D'Amelio sisters
Addison Rey and a vani Greg for now none
of the young ladies have commented on
this split however secrets are bound to
be spilled sooner than later
it looks like older House members are
bumping heads with Thomas whereas
younger members are choosing to stay
away from the drama 20 year old Daisy
who is well known for having the first
certified real booty has added the label
of hype House co-founder to her
Instagram bio but while Daisy's claims
are justifiable internet trolls are
still bashing her for causing a rift in
the hype house type House isn't the
first creator collective to experience
legal trouble so early in the game
Jake Paul's team 10 and other social
media mansions have also encountered
bumps in the road when attempting
similar pursuits in the end having a
house full of teenagers can be quite the
uphill battle during an exclusive with
savanah sellers Alex Warren explained
that the house has a lot of group
meetings because teenagers have to
express their feelings so clearly the
House members are used to bumping heads
the seams you know we argue we fight we
have our differences but at the end of
the day we all go to bed we still love
each other
Alex also revealed that the group
doesn't have a lot of free time
he stated that they haven't used the
pool for fun since moving in in the end
everything is about making videos which
can take the fun out of tick-tock and
while it looks like the fame and drama
is getting out of hand and
unsurprisingly Thomas Petro is in over
his head
in early March Thomas shared a worrying
post on his Instagram story saying that
his anxiety was so bad he was going to
get sick this came right after Thomas
announced that his personal Instagram
page had been hacked fans were quick to
point a finger at Daisy Keach and so was
Thomas he blamed her for the hacking
without naming her telling his followers
that someone had paid to have him hacked
Daisy who has previously had access to
the hype house accounts password had
been locked out by Thomas and Lil hoodie
just a couple of days before the
incident took place on top of getting
hacked Thomas also revealed that the
hacker had tried to get into his PayPal
venmo cash app and bank account in an
attempt to steal all of his money Thomas
has since then stopped following Daisy
on his personal Instagram page amidst
all the drama
Charlie D'Amelio guest-starred on The
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon where
she talked about what was really going
on in the hype house according to
Charlie the secret to her fame is being
authentic the tick-tock er told Jimmy
that she doesn't post videos when she's
not in the mood because she wants her
smiles to be as genuine as possible
however tick-tock errs have to upload up
to four videos a day to remain in good
standing with the hype house's strict
rule book for now Charlie has yet to
comment on the height house's legal
battles she's not choosing sides or
delving into the topic but she did
reveal that a lot is in the works for
her and her sister and she told her fans
to stay tuned for updates during an
interview with today sippy Anna sellers
asked the House members if they were
ever exhausted by the level of fame they
had attained and the crew quickly
revealed that they felt a little
overwhelmed
Avani Gregg told Savannah that they're
constantly attacked online for every
little mistake they make the members
looked exhausted and unhappy as they
talked about their daily filming
schedules Thomas chimed in saying that
living in hype house was like living on
a movie
said it never stopped said the founder
and well cover can attest to that
she told Savannah that she wakes up to
the people filming videos on her balcony
in the morning Thomas chimed in saying
that they have a house of 20 people
posting three to four times a day
trading a total of a hundred and fifty
videos on the daily yeah that map
doesn't quite add up but regardless it
just goes to show how exhausted everyone
is at the hype house Avani also revealed
that she doesn't live in the mansion
full-time because if she did she would
never get any of her homework done in
the end the hype house isn't a place for
a rest
it's a place where famous stick talkers
go to create new content for their fans
but while it's all smiles and games on
social media things are falling apart
behind the scenes
Daisy Keats refuses to stay silent any
longer and hype House members are
flocking to her side for now it looks
like Patrick Connor Calvin and Wyatt are
standing behind their girl Daisy however
most of the other hype House members
have refused to comment on the entire
situation despite all the legal battles
Daisy is hard at work trying to create a
hype house of her own however the name
of her mansion is subject to change
depending on how the legal battles turn
out do you think Daisy should start her
own creator collective or are these
stars taking the fun out of tick tock by
turning it into a business sound off in
the comments thanks for watching for
more fun videos be sure to subscribe to
the things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
you